are you gonna go see Oppenheimer
yeah I'm really excited for it people
are saying it's Gonna Save Hollywood oh
you know it's banned in Japan
they're not showing it in Japan which
makes should we just show it anyway like
against their will
there's two showings
[Laughter]
no I think that I think that it's going
to be great man I mean I love Nolan he's
a beast and he's got a great cast and
the story is great I mean you already
see how they're organizing it like it
feels like Ford vs Ferrari but for
nuclear weapons like just even for the
the trends like it's like we have to do
it they've got a 12-month head start on
us or 18 Germany he's got a 12 or 16
month head start on building nucleus we
have to do it this is the only way we
could win the war you know bring the
boys together the most important thing
in history yeah yeah so apparently it's
not a fan they just haven't had like an
official release date yet so they're
like trying to figure out the release
date but I can think of a good date
what date Black Friday
[Laughter]
the day that will live on an infamy or
whatever Pearl Harbor yeah they could do
it on theirs December 7th yeah they
could do it on there they could do it on
their big day it's funny that like
they're doing joint marketing for Barbie
and Oppenheimer at the same time I've
seen a lot of dreams about that it's
great because now nobody else can
promote yeah it's crazy oh so just to
let everybody know that if you're in Sag
which is the actors Union or the
resident you you it's you not only you
can't act you can't promote your films
so you can't even like come on a podcast
and promote like you can't do anything
to promo it is like pens down so they're
using all of their old press junket
footage like if you see any footage of
the actors together it's promoting film
it's old [__] and you can I guess use
the old stuff to promote it it's just no
more new things
so
I don't know I think it's genius that
they're going into this like meme
marketing
to get Buzz for the movies and uh and it
seems to be working out are they the
same Studio are they completely
different no clue like the fact that
they're riding the wave together I'm
just assuming that's just in solidarity
because they can't promote yeah and so
even if the students hate each other
they're like we got it I think they're
gonna win a lot of these actors are
striking yeah I think they're jumping on
a wave that existed before when people
found out that Barbie and op and iron
were coming out the same time now it's
smart that they both come out the same
time because you would think that the
audiences might be different yeah op and
I are probably excused more male yeah
maybe a little bit older Barbie you're
gonna have the uh weirdos
not weirdos just feet men feet
so we got
you know like I don't know you just feel
like I just feel like yeah maybe women
go see Barbie got the older women who
played when they were young and maybe
the younger women are into it so it's
like then the kids
do the kids
important to children I don't think it
is I think so I was actually at my
friends
daughter's birthday party she's turning
I think eight and yeah she's still into
Barbie kids still watch Sesame Street
all this [__] came back interesting it
went away for a while I think and then
it came back because remember when Adam
Sandler put out that movie with the uh
video games yeah yeah yeah what's that
called pixels pixels
and he used all these games that were
popular when we were kids and the youth
now just didn't really grow up playing
them yeah now what was pretty surprising
is that
[__] uh Mario the Mario Super Mario
Brothers movie did work so I guess Super
Mario Brothers is still popular they
kept developing new games and stuff kids
could still play Nothing exactly massive
I don't know if that's because of the
movie Yo Legos feels bigger now than it
was when we were kids movies yeah they
just had the toys [__] that's right the
movie yeah yeah it was really just like
a building project when you're a kid it
was so much fun I loved it yeah I didn't
I had no creativity I couldn't do it but
you don't need it they got the uh it
wasn't you build your own it's like you
follow the instructions to make it cool
I keep asked parents just bought a big
trouble poor people you didn't have real
Legos you had the fake ones that like
didn't really clicks my [__] clicked I
think but we had Legos it was just it
was brand new it wasn't like you just
had the bucket and then you can make
your own things but yellow red so I was
making a squares and green is it I was
making bigger squares that's like
pediatrician Legos like you ever go to
the pediatrician when you're a kid they
got the sick room with just a bucket old
sick Legos just full of [__] snon
coming [__] was disgusting it was just
in a bucket song pediatrician right
oh